octopus drummers snazzy outfits and the
one reason you don't want to be the
seventh Batman keep watching for the
lowdown on Jason momoa's Aquaman
before Aquaman came along Jason Momoa
was best known for playing the role of
the Barbarian warlord Carl Drogo in Game
of Thrones as well as a less than Stella
turn as Conan the Barbarian in a
critically derided reboot of that
franchise basically the actor had made a
name for himself playing rough and couth
anti-heroes rather than kingly
superheroes when Momoa first got the
call from Warner to audition for the DC
EU he did not imagine for a second that
he was being offered the role for
Aquaman I'm like I'm just gonna bestly
be the bad guy I'm gonna fight Batman
and Superman exactly I'm gonna play the
villain first Momoa was soon informed by
director Zack Snyder that he would
instead be auditioning to play Aquaman
the actor had a hard time imagining
himself as a character from the comics
however Snyder who was a huge fan of
memo was turning as Carl Drogo assured
the actor that he would be the right
choice to bring Aquaman to the big
screen
on the surface there seems to be little
in common between Jason Momoa and
Aquaman the character in the comics is
very blonde and very white and in his
initial on-screen appearances totally
light-hearted he's more of a holdover
from the Golden Age of comics and
someone who encapsulates auroria
physique and brooding presence of Momoa
but the actor found he had more in
common with Arthur Curry than previously
suspected but MOA is of native Hawaiian
descent and Aquatic activities for a
part of the actor's life long before
Aquaman Came Calling in fact he even has
some real life experience with the
classic Aquaman track when he was asked
whether he had been practicing telepathy
with sea creatures Momoa told a crowd at
Walker Stalker Khan no but I rode some
Dolphins before so I can pull on that
additionally Momoa has revealed that he
had been studying to become a marine
biologist before he decided to take a
chance on becoming an actor but the
greatest thing about playing Aquaman for
Momoa was that it allowed him to pay
tribute for Polynesian Gods he told
Walker Stalker Khan our Gods Karo Ali
Maui or these water Gods it's really
cool and an honor to be playing a water
character
despite enjoying a positive reception
after his initial cameo in Batman vs
Superman dawn of Justice and his larger
role in Justice League Aquaman still had
to prove himself with a solo movie
luckily Momoa had the help of perennial
hitmaker James Wan who was able to craft
Aquaman into a Blockbuster movie that
fans and critics alike could get behind
Aquaman was a major departure for one he
was better known for his horror movies
and he chose the character because
Aquaman was relatively unknown to
mainstream film audiences at the time he
told Business Insider the studio asked
me which superhero I would be interested
in I picked Aquaman because it's the one
everyone makes fun of so there wouldn't
be a lot of pressure free of the burden
of expectations one was able to craft
his own unique take on the superhero
genre he explained to vital Thrills my
template wasn't other superhero films my
template was more like traditional
Adventure fantasy films or coming of age
stories rite of passage and all of that
kind of stuff inspired by fantasy films
from the 8 disease mom was able to
charge a radical narrative for Aquaman's
big screen debut that feels excitingly
different yet comfortingly familiar at
the same time
if you were to ask most actors about
their dream DC Superhero role chances
are you're going to hear the word Batman
certainly few actors would choose
Aquaman who had long been seen as a
walking punchline but I've got friends
coming over tonight these lobsters
walked right up to the door anyone
hungry but Jason Momoa always knew he
had the opportunity to do something
special with the character the actor
told the independent that when he was
hired to play Arthur Curry he was given
the freedom to interpret the character
in a new way from the ground up
according to Momoa he was chosen for the
role due to certain personal attributes
that he could transfer to the character
helping to bring Aquaman to life in a
compelling manner when it was time to
make a solo movie James won also
encouraged Momoa to continue to
interpret the character in his own way
with so much creative freedom maybe it's
not surprising that Momoa would prefer
to be Aquaman than yet another Batman he
said it's nice not being the seventh
Batman it's nice to be the first one and
good luck being the next one
during many superhero debuts lead actors
face the uphill task of making audiences
care about an unknown character but when
Jason Momoa signed on to play Aquaman he
had an even more difficult task making
the public like a superhero who had been
actively mocked and treated as a joke
for decades of course sucks Nadia and
Warner took the right step by casting an
actor who could look badass doing
literally anything Momoa was very aware
that he needed to reinvent Aquaman as a
commanding and imposing figure which is
why he had a strong dislike for a line
in just whedon's 2017 version of Justice
League I hear you can talk to fish
Mamoa later told ew I'm like don't put
this line in there because that's all
people are gonna talk about do you want
me to make him cool or not fortunately
that one-off joke was not enough to
detract from the energy that Momoa
brought to the role iconic Comic Book
Heroes often have iconic Origins and
filmmakers change those stories at their
Peril Aquaman's origin story is less
well known however and filmmaker James 1
made plenty of changes to it while
making his 2018 movie The most obvious
difference is that Aquaman in the comics
is blonde head blue eyed and pale
whereas Jason Momoa is of Polynesian
descent his version of Arthur Curry is
shown to be of mixed race then there's
the fact that in the comics Aquaman is
usually depicted as a very serious
character who is acutely conscious of
his Royal Heritage and his manner of
speaking reflects his Noble birth but in
the movie Arthur is closer to momoa's
real life personality a fun-loving dude
bro type who drinks beer and bars and
doesn't take himself too seriously the
details of Aquaman's journey to becoming
the king of Atlantis also turn out much
differently than they do in the comics
2018's Aquaman is sometimes described as
a little over the top and the biggest
example of this access is generally
considered to be the fight scene between
Arthur and orm in which among other
things an octopus can be seen playing
the drums the octopus drummer might seem
like a bizarre addition to the movie but
there are actually a couple of solid
reasons for its presence first of all
the octopus and the film is inspired by
toppo Aquaman's longtime octopus Ally in
the comics who played a variety of
musical instruments James One Told The
Huffington Post so I'm like okay how do
I take that and bring it into my movie
and make it cool additionally once or a
drum playing octopus place in the middle
of the action as essentially fulfilling
the same role as the war red guitarist
from Mad Max Fury Road he explained to
the metro in that movie there is
literally a guitar guy having flames
shooting from his instrument it doesn't
do anything for the narrative but it
creates a really unique world that was
my goal for the drum playing Octopus as
well oh what a day a lovely day one of
the things that makes Aquaman better
than the average superhero movie is that
it does not wholly revolve around Arthur
Curry but is instead filled with other
interesting characters who make a real
impact on the plot two such characters
are Arthur's parents whose relationship
with each other and Arthur Powers a
central Narrative of the film the role
of Arthur's father Tom is played by
veteran actor timwara Morrison who
credits Jason Momoa with getting him the
part apparently Mamoa had been inspired
by Morrison's role in one's World
Warriors Morrison told now to love Jason
saw once were warriors when he was
growing up in Iowa and because his
father's Hawaiian it really impinged on
his cultural Consciousness and identity
meanwhile Nicole Kidman agreed to play
Queen Alana and Aquaman mainly due to
her desire to work with the film's
director she told ew James 1 is a really
good friend of mine and he offered to
let me play Queen Atlanta as soon as he
said I could wear mother of pearl and be
a mermaid Warrior I said I'm done please
if there is one thing I have to do my my
life I have to be that the actress saw
the role as an opportunity to have some
fun while working with a director whom
she had long admired
the character of Aquaman went through a
few changes from his classic look or
making the jump to live action films but
the truth is that Aquaman includes three
distinctly famous looks for Arthur Curry
from the comics by featuring them on
members of his extended family first up
is Arthur himself his look closely
resembles the Aquaman from the comics in
the 90s when the character had long
locks body armor resembling the tattoos
from the film and the disinclination to
wear a shirt then there is the classic
bright blonde haired clean shaven look
for Aquaman from the comics which in the
movie was given to warm finally there's
a suit given to Arthur and orm's
ancestor King Gatlin the classic green
and gold colors of the Aquaman suit from
the comics combined with a royal cloak
and a crown this look closely resembles
a much older Arthur Curry's uniform in
Alex Ross and Mark Way's classic graphic
novel series Kingdom Come
while Arthur Curry and his half-brother
om are the center of the story in
Aquaman fans also responded well to the
supporting villain Black Manta he was
played by Yaya Abdul Mateen II after
Arthur allows manza's father to die
early in the movie the latter is
overcome with the desire for revenge and
his journey towards Vengeance begs for a
compelling subplot kill him and the
woman he's with and you will be rewarded
killing him is my reward in the comics
Black Manta is one of Aquaman's most
famous enemies but he almost didn't make
the cut when the studio Was preparing
Aquaman for his first live-action movie
it was a combined efforts of director
James 1 and producer Jeff Johns that
kept Black Manta in the script and
looking just like he does in the comics
John's told Geeks of color there was a
moment when the script was really going
and James texted me or emailed me and
said Black Manta story may be too big
for this movie and I didn't reply I just
went to his office and I said Black
Manta has to be in the movie he was like
I know fortunately Mansa did become a
part of Aquaman and he is expected to
appear in the upcoming sequel too
a few eyebrows are raised and Jason
Momoa was first cast as Aquaman in the
DC EU the actor proved all than they say
is wrong however when he became a huge
fan favorite and helped score the solo
Aquaman movie a billion dollar growth at
the box office and now the actor is
ready to kick his involvement with the
franchise up a notch in 2021 while
discussing Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom
on the Drew Barrymore show Mamoa
revealed that he felt so strongly about
the direction the superhero franchise
should take that he came up with a
treatment for the sequel we did the
first treatment and then James and our
original writer David finished it off
and you know all of our hearts are in it
the actor also revealed that he felt
much more involved in the project as a
writing partner than he would have if he
had simply been following a script and
however the lost kingdom turns out one
thing seems to be certain Jason Momoa is
going to be sticking with Aquaman for a
long time to come
foreign